joining us now South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham Liz senator could you
thank you known you a long time yeah 20
years as it was happening I was live on
my radio show and when I had my next
break I don't think you ever had a more
powerful moment in your career and I've
known you a long time thank you well I
just told the truth this is not about
finding the truth between dr. Ford and
Brett Kavanaugh
it's about delaying the hearing until
get past the midterms hope they pick up
the Senate and denying this seat to be
filled by Donald Trump it's not about
the FBI if you really wanted to know
what the FBI thought about this you were
to come forward when you first know
about it it's certainly not about
protecting dr. Ford the one thing I
learned beyond any doubt today any doubt
is this they never intended to protect
dr. Ford and everything I believed I
knew about Brett Kavanaugh I am now more
convinced than ever that he didn't do it
that he's the right guy to be on the
court that miss Ford has got a problem
and destroying judge Cavanaugh's life
won't fix her problem and if we
legitimize this god help us all because
both sides can do this to my friends on
the other side I would never have done
this to one of your nominees you should
be ashamed you voted for people that I
know you know not share their judicial
philosophy picked used to be if you're a
qualified elections matter here's what
the big picture is elections don't
matter to them they only matter when
they win now when we win when Donald
Trump wins there are no rules there are
no boundaries
president Trump today I hope you
understand why pick Brett Kavanaugh not
only is the incredibly qualified judge a
incredibly decent man he and his wife
are the parents of the year if they're
going to give out an award for parenting
I'd give it to Ashley and Brett based on
what their girl his daughter said about
who to pray for so I'm honored to help
him if I helped him today is one of the
highlights of my career in to my
Republican colleagues if this guy goes
down and then we don't deserve to stay
in power because it's not about power to
me it is about the process it is about
honor
election stood my Democratic Prince Joe
mentioned I like him a lot Joe you can't
figure this out Trump went about 40
points do you really believe that Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial rapist
do you believe any of this garbage you
know I'm sorry that dr. Ford went
through this she shouldn't have had to
go through it but I am convinced beyond
any shadow of a doubt there Brett
Kavanaugh is not the man that they're
trying to make him and this is all
political so Joe I'll appeal step up
Heidi I like you a lot Joe Donnelly
great guy why can't you talk about
whether or not we've met the burden here
if you if he had to prove he was
innocent he did it for me but he doesn't
have to me ask you Republicans met in
conference tonight in the Senate bring
us inside the meeting as much as you are
able to share I went well I think
everybody was blown away Barbara can you
imagine doing what he did today no your
life has been ripped apart you had a
32-hour hearing you meet with every
senator they've known about this for
weeks and they spring you spring it on
you at the end then it goes to where
avenatti comes out and says you're a
serial rapist you drugged women gang
rape gang rape and everyone in the halls
and your whole life is just absolutely
destroyed I think Republicans today felt
like Brett Kavanaugh not only met the
test passed the test that this is
political and I will be brokenhearted if
the Senate rejects this good man bob
corker said yes Jeff good for Bob Jeff
Flake off camera said this is a tough
one
Wow we just say I would just say Jeff it
is tough because I I don't know what
happened to dr. Ford but I've been a
lawyer role model I used to do this
stuff for a living Jeff you couldn't get
a warrant she can't tell you where it
happened when it happened it's not he
said she said
it's that she said and they said all
people named said it didn't have four
and you can't give the date and the time
and my god he he went through a calendar
of 1982 this is the most squared away
guy I've ever met in my life
I was just honored to be in his prime
if again I've never seen anybody command
a room like he did I've never seen
anybody more sincere and I've never seen
anybody more used and abused than dr.
Ford was by the Democrats let me ask you
then it seems Jeff Flake Susan Collins
Lisa Murkowski and I I've actually been
quoting Susan Collins because she's the
one that slightly pointed out from the
beginning this has been unfair to both
sides here and she's right she's been
right about that yeah well what I would
tell Susan is it
if you're the way they say Brett is you
wouldn't have the life Brett is lived
you wouldn't have 65 women coming
forward you wouldn't have six FBI
investigations that found nothing and
you wouldn't be in this profile of a job
he's been in the highest levels of
government a target for 26 years you
find out about it after the hearings
over they knew about it they said on it
there's no corroboration and the
avenatti thing tells you all they need
to know about where they're headed with
him if we delay this there'll be more
coming and he doesn't deserve it it is
time to vote
the Senate Judiciary Committee will meet
tomorrow morning yes walk us through the
process the full Senate with what we
expect what Tuesday yeah we will vote
tomorrow in committee I will go through
why I believe he's qualified and capable
I will tell you without any hesitation
what I think's happened here in the
confirmation process if this is the new
norm god help us all I think he will get
reported out of committee a longer party
line vote I hope Jeff can get there I
would just stress again that this man
has led an incredible life everything
they're saying about him is made up and
it comes out of the left field and it's
not corroborated please don't take away
everything he's done he's number one in
his class ever ever since he's you know
done anything and and I think we're
going to getting confirmed and if we go
to the floor of the Senate we're gonna
pick up some Democrats
let me put let me tell you this if you
live in these Trump States and you can't
figure this out and good luck to you let
me ask you one last question as you look
at the emotion of today and all that
happened I I I'm like one of my best
friend from third grade his name is John
Gomez and John called me yesterday as
Hannity you always say every two four
years and Republicans have racist sexist
my whole list as he calls it
and he goes I think I understand it a
little more now why you always do it
because when you say these horrible
things and now we've gotten used to it
we expect it you know it's like my
father was killed all over again elect
Republicans and black churches will burn
our crosses are going to burn or
Republicans don't want to count
african-americans in the census how war
said this has to stop senator those are
political arguments that we can handle
and people obviously know this is
destroying somebody yeah I would hope
and pray that I never get this desperate
as a political person to destroy
somebody this was a wholesale effort to
take a good man and ruin his life and it
backfired on them this is not about
political arguments this is not about
what they will do what we will do this
is about the fact that they were willing
to set a man up and destroy his life and
there's hard to watch this that it was
really hard to watch and when he talked
about his daughter you know let's let's
let's pray for the lady too this is a
good man please vote for him you know
senator I think the reason your moment
was so powerful is it was raw and real
and unplanned it was totally and I
totally real I think you reflected
defense in many Americans know what got
me was why won't you agree to the FBI
investigation what do you got to hide
these are the same people that said on
the information that made it impossible
for us to do an investigation because
they wouldn't help us knew it for weeks
plan what they're doing intentionally I
am convinced out of dr. Ford for the
political moment that we saw today and
it blew up in their face and I hope
America understands that if this is the
new way of doing business we're going in
the wrong direction and we've got a
chance to turn it around beginning
tomorrow at 9:30 and in 40 days the
American people get their chance senator
thank you so much for be appreciate it